c'est l'heure du journal de l'Afrique
soit il est bienvenus sur France 24 à la
une ce soir le sort des étudiants
africains en Ukraine un grand nombre
d'entre eux ne sont pas parvenus à
quitter le pays certains affirment ne
pas avoir été autorisés à passer la
frontière polonaise lui à se dit
préoccupé par la situation et de
nombreux pays tentent d'évacuer leur
ressortissants en écoutera des
témoignages et l'analyse de gauthierry
et nous parlerons également du
positionnement des pays du Maghreb dans
ce conflit la position neutre de la
Tunisie l'appel au dialogue du Maroc et
le jeu d'équilibriste de l'Algérie qui
est courtisé pour son gaz mais qui ne
doit pas froisser son allié historique
la Russie décryptage de notre invité et
Hasna Abidi politologue et spécialiste
du monde arabe
depuis quelques jours des images et des
témoignages afflux sur les réseaux
sociaux on y voit des étudiants
africains bloqués en Ukraine à qui on
interdit l'accès aux trains des
étudiants qu'on empêche de passer la
frontière polonaise pour fuir la guerre
nous avons pu contacter quelques
étudiants beaucoup nous confirment
l'effet mais refuse de témoigner tant
qu'ils ne sont pas tant qu'ils n'ont pas
quitté l'Ukraine nous avons pu joindre
le président national des Ivoiriens
d'Ukraine ucénie Sidibé son pays a prêté
des bus à la frontière polonaise pour
aider à l'évacuation de ces
ressortissants mais pour le moment la
situation reste compliquée écoutez-le il
répondait aux questions de Célia
caracena
c'est d'abord général en tant que
africain on nous repousse pas de
justifications on bloque à la rentrée de
la frontière polonaise mais nous avons
Jésus nos autorités nous essayons de
nous mettre à l'abri les Ivoiriens dans
la ville stable de vivre nous ne sommes
pas du tout à l'abri à
Ève à quartier à Odessa est-ce que vous
manquez d'eau et de nourriture
de nourriture nous sommes livrés à
nous-mêmes nous sommes quelques uns de
nos compatriotes de nos frères de notre
nationalités qui ont pu traverser la
frontière
en témoignait comme quoi ils ont bel et
bien été reçus
il y a le polonais qui donne à manger
qui donne à boire l'État de Côte
d'Ivoire après les mesures nous pensons
que demain déjà voilà notre problème
sera revenu on sera à l'abri et il nous
a été demandé que tous nos
ressortissants ivoiriens
et cette différence de traitement entre
européen et africain c'est aussi invité
à la tribune de l'ONU écouté à ce propos
l'ambassadeur du Gabon aux Nations Unies
de ressortissants et étudiants africains
y compris les étudiants de mon pays qui
fuyant la guerre en Ukraine se heurte à
des discriminations dans leur exode et
leur quête d'abris
de nombreux témoignages parlent d'acte
de racisme
cela est inacceptable
nous demandons le respect de la dignité
et appelons à un traitement équitable de
toutes les personnes en détresse
c'est le lieu pour mon pays d'amplifier
l'appel de l'Union africaine au respect
du droit international qui s'applique en
pareil circonstances et qui prescrit un
égal traitement pour toute personne
franchissant les frontières
internationales dans un conflit
voilà vous l'avez entendu la situation
inquiète l'Union africaine qui a
condamné dans un communiqué je cite le
traitement différent inacceptable
choquant et raciste ce phénomène va à
l'encontre des valeurs que défend
l'Union européenne comme nous l'explique
gauthierrybinsky écoutez
si on veut montrer d'abord que cette
guerre sert à quelque chose c'est de
détruire le système Poutine Poutine
fonctionne sur des terroristes des
théories pardon raciales et racialistes
sur ce qui est être russe donc il n'y a
aucune raison pour que des citoyens
africains noirs ou arabes soient traité
de la sorte au motif qu'il ne soit pas
blanc parce que sinon pardonnez-moi mais
ça fout tout par terre donc il s'agit
pas maintenant de transiger il faut
attendre de manière très ferme que les
autorités polonaises comme ukrainiennes
ne fasse pas de tri parce que les
Africains qui sortent du crâne sont
comme les autres des personnes menacées
et que précisément si on veut que
l'Europe rudor son blason dans cette
affaire mais ça consiste aussi à traiter
en parfaite équité les citoyens de
quelques pays que ce soit alors je sais
bien c'est compliqué il y a des
problèmes administratifs de consulat de
transport de personnes très bien mais
nous avons vu des images et que on n'a
pas encore vu tout à fait mais les
images où on voit par exemple des
policiers qui soient Ukrainiens ou
polonais rejeter des Africains pour
qu'ils ne puissent pas monter dans un
train ça n'est pas tolérable d'ordinaire
ça ne l'est pas ça ne l'est encore moins
parce que si ce qui se joue dans cette
guerre c'est pas des questions de
territoire c'est des questions aussi de
dignité humaine de ces comportements
racistes aux frontières de l'Ukraine et
de la situation des étudiants africains
mais il faut tout de même préciser qu'il
y a d'autres d'autres qui témoignent de
solidarité des Ukrainiens qui fuient à
leur côté c'est le cas d'un jeune
congolais il a été joint par nos équipes
écoutez-le c'est
organisé et nous avons tous apprécié
cela après à tous les 100 ou 200 mètres
il y a des volontaires qui ont amené des
des biens de l'eau de la nourriture pour
enfants une volontaire sont là ils sont
en train de donner de la nourriture à
tout le monde l'eau du café du lait et
voire même ses Pampers pour bébé le
peuple craignait vraiment cet organisé à
5 que toutes les personnes qui quittent
le pays ne puisse manquer de rien qu'il
ne puisse pas quitter le pays affamés
jusque là je n'ai pas été contacté par
l'ambassade de la RDC et nous n'avons
pas de représentation diplomatique en
Ukraine et avec la Pologne nous avons
tenté de contacter mais
l'appel n'est pas passé et après
plusieurs essais nous avons décidé de
prendre des choses en main tout seul et
de nous diriger et à la frontière
Gauthier quand on suit
quand il y a ce genre de témoignage
absolument et il faut il faut le
souligner il y a d'autres témoignages
aussi sur des Hongrois des Polonais qui
apportent des couvertures à toute
personne quel que soit leur couleur de
peau à la frontière ukrainienne
Gauthier quand on suit l'actualité
africaine on ne peut pas s'empêcher de
se poser cette question que se
passe-t-il dans les cercles du pouvoir
malien et centrafricains qui ont choisi
Moscou comme allié est-ce que cette
guerre finalement les conforte dans leur
décision ou la situation est plus que
jamais incertaine
je dirais qu'on est on fait face dans ce
cas là à au fond une sorte de j'allais
dire des séquelles du tiers mondisme
c'est-à-dire que la perception il n'y a
pas que les États africains d'ailleurs
la perception qu'on peut avoir de la
Russie c'est comme l'héritière de
l'Union soviétique et l'Union soviétique
avait soutenue des mouvements
d'indépendance et d'émancipation en
Afrique et donc quand on se retrouve
dans des situations difficiles avec
l'ancien colon français avec des
responsabilités partagées et bien on
cherche un allié de rechange et cette
année de rechange le problème c'est
qu'il n'est pas très regardant sur la
question de la gouvernance et des droits
de l'homme donc on peut comprendre que
la junte malienne ou que le pouvoir
centrafricain soit féru et friand d'une
association avec la Russie qui ne
regardera pas la situation des droits de
l'homme mais qui prétendra soutenir
et et conforté garantir l'unité
territoriale petit problème que fait la
Russie aujourd'hui la garantie
territoriale l'intégrité territoriale de
l'Ukraine elle s'en fiche deuxièmement
sur ce qui concerne la possession des
richesses de ces pays africains on sait
de manière tout à fait normale que les
Russes sont là pour prélever une sorte
de dîme le correspondant à l'heure
association
au Sénégal ce sont des familles qui
s'inquiètent le parrain de Samba Diallo
l'attaquant du Dynamo Kiev et sans
nouvelles de lui il nous a fait part de
son angoisse écouter le fil répondait
aux questions de notre correspondant à
Dakar et l'imam Daho c'est une situation
aujourd'hui
et j'avoue que j'étais très inquiet au
début bon parce que c'est un jeune quand
même même pas 20 ans qui est loin de ses
parents loin de son terroir et qui est
en train de subir des agents de
bombardements
être très malheureux qui a une partie de
moi qui est là-bas et qui qu'il faut que
je sache au moins pour maquiétude que je
puisse avoir donc tous les matins toute
la journée je regarde France 24 pour
être au diapason de ce qui se passe
là-bas bon je vois que plus que des
négociations ont entamé peut-être que ça
ne durera plus longtemps
voilà mais en tout cas c'est 5 jours
terribles bon heureusement maintenant
nous nos compatrides ont été transférés
en
qu'en est-il du Maghreb la région est
indirectement touchée on a vu des
familles marocaines faire un City à
Rabat pour demander aux autorités de
rapatrier leurs enfants bloqués en
Ukraine on a pris également la mort d'un
jeune algérien dans les bombardements
Ukraine comment ces pays se sont-ils
positionnés vis-à-vis de ce conflit
écouter l'analyse de notre invitée
avec nous tout à l'heure
globalement c'est une position prudente
dans tous les pays du Maghreb l'Algérie
a une autre maison de position parce que
elle est courte il disait c'est vrai par
plusieurs pays européens c'est le
troisième fournisseur en gaz de l'Europe
après la Norvège et la Russie et en même
temps on a réussi le premier client en
terme d'armement de la Russie ici
pourquoi ça position elle est très
délicate à la fois d'être un pays qui
aujourd'hui indispensable pour l'Europe
et en même temps elle veut conserver
conserver des bonnes relations avec la
réussite sans avoir la capacité de
production du gaz comme c'est le cas de
la Russie alors
vraiment comme quelles conséquence
économique y aura-t-il dans la région le
prix du pétrole ne cesse de flamber ça
va sans doute arranger certains mais pas
d'autres
absolument le Maroc est dans une
situation très difficile et là et la
connu une saison très difficile en
matière bien sûr de
l'agriculture et c'est un pays qui
importe énormément de blé de la Russie
et du l'Ukraine donc à la fois il est
soumis à l'augmentation de prix donc du
gaz et au début du pétrole et en même
temps il doit aussi se tourner vers
d'autres marchés pour son pour son pain
quotidien le l'Ukraine et la réussite
c'est le panier comme alimentaire de
plusieurs États du Maghreb
voilà c'est la fin du journal de
l'Afrique merci à vous de nous avoir
suivi merci aux équipes en régime merci
à notre chef d'édition Celia carassena
[Musique]